ne revenons pas sur les problèmes
économiques mais vous le savez
l'industrie textile française connaît
une grave crise les couturiers font donc
feu de tout bois pour présenter leurs
productions c'est la période de ce qu'on
appelle les collections france proche a
voulu savoir quelles étaient les grandes
tendances de la mode des prochains mois
peu après le salon du prêt-à-porter
elle a voulu mettre ça à noir sur blanc
ou plutôt en couleurs d'ailleurs pour
nous j'allais tout de même oublier cette
mode n'est pas la vôtre mesdames et sans
vouloir être particulièrement macho je
dirais qu'elle ne concerne que les
hommes et j'entends déjà qu'ils vont
parler de l'homme objet curieux retour
des choses tout de même les hommes ne
sont pas comme certaines voudrait nous
le faire croire
des aiguilleurs de vaisselle en
puissance des tourneurs de sauce
béchamel
qu'irait de temps en temps à battre
quelques arbres non ils peuvent être
aussi des créatures de rêve une preuve
le dictionnaire des parfums masculins
annonce déjà 40 cents heures destinée à
renforcer leur sex-appeal
et puis les tailleurs travail à nous les
renouveler ils sont bientôt chasseurs en
ville avec jade peur exotique pour
renoma pourchassent à la tigresse
norvégien pour claude rey avec pull
jacquard tendrement assortis aux
carreaux de la veste pour chasse à
l'ours anne k line structure propose une
part qu'adp ville importer tout droit
des forêts ou bien elles seront colorés
olivier elle pour cech ne veut un tee
shirt rouge avec un pied poule gris et
puis micmac façonnable et cacharel nous
les promet trozoul et promettre pêche
ars marié en habit jaune tout un
programme
toujours très coloré le style campus
américains
avec blouson aveuglant et pantalons
resserrés à la cheville finis les petits
jean étriqué
beaujard équipe ses boys pour le voyage
avec sac en bandoulière attaché avec
deux manches de tricot la fel la france
prévoit pour les siens des sacs des
teintes tendre attaché à la taille et
esther la poche garni de brosses peigne
dentifrice pour les fugueurs nocturne
les préférez-vous exotiques style mallet
avec bandeaux sur le front et ceintures
drapés ou style chinois ou bien encore
toujours de marcel la cense les jeunes
gens style indien un peu lancé du bagage
râpez encore mais négligé le cheminot
dexter avec pantalons retroussés et
baluchons on respire on respire aussi
avec le futal de péter de sinclair avec
ça on peut déjeuner à l'hôtel
obligatoires
et toujours résolument paysans mais
balkanique
les ensembles de jef serre on peut les
porter sans bouquet mais ça serait
dommage alors chasseurs étudiants
orientale aux moissonneurs les darons
c'est beau jeu